Hello, everyone. Thank you for joining us
in this session.
AI M 380 customized Amazon Nova
models for enhanced stool calling.
We appreciate you spending the time with us. There are some
information sheets in front of you that tell us, tell
you, uh, what kind of fine tuning techniques
and models we are going to cover in this session.
My name is Hirsha Asnani. I'm a worldwide specialist
G AI essay at AWS. With
me, uh, joins Anupam.
Hi, this is Anupam. I am senior Solutions architect
in NoA team, so happy to be here
to introduce the customization
features that we have launched, yeah.
Perfect. So, a quick overview of the
agenda. We'll go into uh a
little bit of concepts of what model customization
is, what key considerations
are for model customization, especially for
tool calling. So what techniques are
available, what we used.
We'll quickly also go over the recent
reinvent launches about
Nova, and from there, we'll dive
deep into the code talk, um, take
you through some code that we've developed uh in
this session to show you how you can enhance
tool calling capabilities using Amazon Nova
models.
OK. Why
model customization, right? So before we dive
into Nova's customization capabilities,
let's get into the spectrum of uh
customization techniques available,
not just in Nova, but generally on uh
foundation models.
So it all starts with choosing
if you have to modify the weights or
not of the model, and you can see
from the left to the right, the level of customization
and effort increases when you try
to
change the weights of the model
on the left is a light touch technique.
Uh, you could try something like prompt engineering
where you tell the model
the way you want it, uh, the model to respond
in a particular format,
but essentially, uh, the model still
retains the concepts that it has
been trained on. So if you have new concepts,
uh, that are specific to your
organization's data or, you know, the styles
that you are used to.
You can probably provide that in a prompt engineering
um text
and a couple of examples and um basically
just take an off the shelf model
and see how it performs for you.
You can also use RAAG,
uh, which is short for retrieval augmented
generation, and what that lets you do is also
without
modifying the weights of your model.
It lets you provide organization-specific
data at the time of inference. So,
again, if the model hasn't learned some things, um,
uh, after it was trained,
but you have in your organization's corpus,
uh, it will pick it up and uh respond accordingly.
There are times where um
you will see uh with
these approaches that you will see saturation,
you'll probably see styles of responses
not matching up exactly
to what you need, which is where you go to the right
side. Uh, these techniques
will modify the weights of the model. Uh, they're
divided into post and pre-training
all the way to the right is pre-training with, uh,
and with pre-training, what you do is, uh,
basically the use cases.
If there are concepts again in your
uh organization that haven't been learned
in a model, you can uh use
pre-training concepts, uh sorry, uh, pre-training
techniques, but
if you only want to modify the model for the
style of responses,
uh,
in a particular format, then you could
use something like post training which also modifies
the weights of the model,
but is not as intense and doesn't
require as many
resources or expertise, uh, to train
the model.
So, now that we've, uh, understood the progression of
the customization techniques, let's get into
how you can do this with Amazon, uh,
AWS,
uh, especially for Nova models, we have
Uh, two offerings,
SageMaker fully managed training jobs
and SageMaker Hyperpod.
What SageMaker training jobs let you do is
define your training workload through declarative
syntax and Python SDKs,
where you provide your custom training scripts, your
data, and it just takes care of everything
about spinning Docker containers, bringing them
down, observability, scalability, things like
that. But if you're coming more from
a background of EKS and you like
more control on, you know, getting into your EC2
instances, SSH into it,
and you have a requirement for maximization of
control, you can uh use SageMaker
Hyperpod as well.
With that, I'll hand it over to one of them to go
over some launches.
Yeah, thanks, Ash.
Uh, yeah, so we'll basically go over some
of the launches that happened this year
in keynotes.
Uh, primarily, first is
the addition of different models that
we added.
So you can see the first generation models
that were released last year, Micro Light and Pro.
Hopefully you guys played with it and
using it.
Uh, the second generation is something that we
launched the day before
yesterday, which was Nova Light 2 Nova
Nova 2 Light.
Um, and that is again, uh,
a new generation model, um,
built from the scratch up with
newer training data, improved, uh,
improvements on more multilingual
capabilities, more agentic use cases,
more coding abilities,
so it shines in those cases. There
are public reports available so you can
read the technical report which has very
clear benchmarks
and comparisons with other models.
And then we also. Released two of the
early access model or private preview as
we call it, which is the Nova 2 Pro,
which is like a,
a Big Brother to light, uh, is a bigger
model but more better in terms of knowledge
and intelligence,
and then Omni, which is uh N2 image
and text, that means you can pass in any modality,
and it kind of answers back either in text
or the image, for example, the kind
of mixture of a
NA probe with Canvas,
for example. Apart
from the base model launches, we also
released uh something called A Noa Forge,
which is, uh, which is basically, uh, open
training concept,
uh, where you get, uh,
you get not just the base model
or the recipes for customization, but
you also get
intermediate checkpoints of. Nova, which
you can use to get started with your customization.
Until now, you only could use the
final checkpoint, which was the production model
that everybody would have access to,
but this allows you to get a mid-trained, uh,
previously trained, only CPT trained
so that you can start from various other
checkpoints as well.
Apart from checkpoints, we also, uh,
added NOAA data, which means that
you can mix NAA data with your data
when you are training.
So there have been scientific evidences
that show that when you do a mix-in
between your data and the data
of the
LLM that it has seen when it was training,
it increases the learning capability
of the model.
So yeah, those are some of the key value props
slash benefits of Nova Pro. You
get access to multiple different checkpoints
rather than just the last checkpoint.
You can blend your proprietary data with
Amazon NoA curated data. You
can also use reinforcement learning
by bringing your own environment, uh, which
means like, we work with customers who
have built their own environment where
they do reward function calculation.
And use that to improve the model
and they didn't want to move the whole set up to
AWS because you have
invested and created that whole environment.
So this lets you just hook up that uh
external environment, which is calculating
the reward function
while training the model in the BPC.
And then, yes, it comes with the push button
recipes. So you get like pre-baked recipes
with the most optimal values for multiple
hyperparameters that you can use.
Um, and then lastly, you also get a responsible
AI toolkit, so that if you have a, like
a security use case or
a content moderation use case, you can utilize
the, and modify or customize the
responsible AI layer of Nova as well.
Um, so yeah, that's pretty much
the launches. Uh, this, this table
gives you a higher-level overview of
the 1.0 offerings and then 2.0
offerings,
uh, in terms of different techniques. Like
Harsh mentioned, they are post-training. So like
if you see parameter efficient fine tuning, which
is a type of fine tuning where you are
only changing the adapter
of the model,
uh, as well as full rank fine tuning where
you're changing actual.
Rates of the model both are available
in 1.0 and 2.0.
DPO is another kind of, uh,
post training where you are getting like that
thumbs up, thumbs down feedback, and you
want to teach model what a good looks like versus
what a bad looks like
so that it can steer towards
your preferences or human preferences.
Uh, that is also available in 1.0
and similarly PPO, which is another
class of very similar to.
but another class of, uh, RLHF
technique.
And then, uh, we have reinforcement
fine-tuning, which is the state of the
art RLHF as of today, which
is available in 2.0. And
the reason why it is only in 2.0 is because
RLHF works or RFT, which is
reinforcement fine tuning, works much
better on a reasoning model, and NAA Light
2 is a reasoning model.
So that's why that combination.
With that, we will jump into the use case and
just give you a brief idea of what we are going to
do today, um,
rather than spending too much on PPT we'll move to
code now, but
so the use case, uh, architecture that
we're going to pick today is a security
agreement legal assistant agent. So
this agent would be responsible for looking
through the multiple documents and,
uh, and then we will give it a question and it has
to pick the right tool to call.
To get access to the right information,
right parameters to pick, and then, uh,
go from there.
So in different modules that we will
cover, firstly, we will, uh,
teach you how synthetic data generator works
or how you can generate your own data
because we see a lot of customers who don't have
the data to begin with when you come to customization,
and that is like a P0 or pre
prerequisite.
So we'll work, give you some sneak peek
on what, uh, synthetic data
generator we have been using, uh, for this
particular demo.
And then, uh, do a base model evaluation
just to get, OK, where we are from just
the base model without any customization.
Move on to supervised fine tuning. That's
the first thing we would use for
fine tuning with prompt response pairs.
Do an eval on that post-SFT
checkpoint,
uh, to get, OK, how much, uh, did we
improve from the base model.
Move on to reinforcement fine-tuning, which
would be sitting on top of the SFT
checkpoint. So it is an iterative, uh,
fine tuning approach.
And then do a post RFT evaluation
to see how that goes.
And then finally, make a deployment to Bedrock
to make inference. So, we'll cover all these
modules in today's code talk. We have very
one hour, but too many modules to cover. So
hopefully, we are good,
uh, there.
But just to give you an idea of what SFT
is, if you are not familiar with it,
it all starts with an adapter trainer, if
you go with the Lora-base technique or parameter
efficient.
That is what we will be showcasing today. It's
the most lightweight SFT you can
do with like limited resources, quick,
uh, you don't really have a lot to spend
and you get decent results in the first
go, or at least give a good signal
if the model is capable of learning for your
use case or not.
So adapter training basically gets the
data
from in, from your database, which it would be S3
in this case. It gets the base model,
uh, from the recipe, and then
it basically do a forward
backward pass
to learn from the data that you're providing
along with the base model,
uh, and gets a trainer, and then you get
the base model, and you do a fusion
where the adapter is fused with the base
model. To get the final model.
So that is what SFT does essentially.
SFT adapter-based training does
essentially.
It's just a light adapter that you're
training and then doing a fusion.
Um,
while RFT is a little more elaborate,
so it has, um,
training VPC customer VPC.
So in training, there are two main modules.
There is a rollout and there's a trainer,
and then in your customer account, there is
the lambda function, which is the reward
function. Um, so
again, you get access to the prompt data, which
is your dataset that you want to train the
model to teach the RFT technique,
and you get the base model.
You, again, load both things from the
rollout and trainer also loads the
base model.
And then it calls the lambda
function to to calculate
the predictions.
So what does rollout do is think
of it like a, uh, uh,
I don't know, a system that generates like
any number of answers.
So rollout is like N number of generations
or N number of predictions and passes
all those predictions to the lambda
to calculate the score based on your evaluation
metric. Uh, it gets the
res responses back, which is basically
rewards. So it gets the rewards back
and then it feeds those rewards
back to the trainer. So trainer can learn
from those answers or from that feedback
and further improve.
And then it does the forward backward pass
on the trainer to get the learnings,
and that's where it goes back to the rollout
to update the weight policy. And this
this cycle continues where more rollouts
are generated, lambda function calculates
the rewards, back passes it back to trainer.
Trainer updates the weights, new rollouts are
generated, and that cycle continues
for a number of steps that you define
in your recipe, and that's how the
model starts learning,
and we'll see today how it happens in real
example. Uh, OK. With
that, I will move on to the code
sample. So, yeah.
Let me switch
OK, so time to dive
right into code soup. So this is a code talk. There's
a bunch of code we've developed, uh, to demonstrate
the use case,
uh, planning to get through all of it in an hour,
uh, but it can get dense. So
we have planned to show you the essential code
blocks
and hide away some of, or glance over,
uh, some of the utility helper functions.
We will take questions at the end of each
notebook, maybe a couple. We'll do a quick time
check, and if there are more questions, we
can just, you know, probably take them out in the hallway.
Uh, this is not a demo and we want to keep this session
educational and interactive. So, uh,
please let us know if you have any questions at the end of the notebooks.
First up is the data prep step. Uh,
what's interesting here is that
instead of taking an existing data set, we
have generated data to fine tune
the foundational models for an
example use case,
uh, essentially just pulling it out of thin air,
uh, and the idea is that if we
can generate this data from silos,
uh, you know, anywhere on the Internet.
Uh,
data that is structured, unstructured, or a combination
and create agentic applications that are hyper-personalized,
you can do the same,
uh, with data existing in your
organization's silos.
Uh, coming back to the use case that we have here,
there are 3 radar sources that we use, and
imagine that the end user is an attorney
or a paralegal or someone who's trying to
ensure securities transactions
like, uh, private stock sales,
public offerings comply with SEC regulations.
We I
do want to point out that you can
use NOAA models for a variety of use
cases, but especially for legal
and healthcare use cases,
please use it at your discretion and
especially with other regulated
and sensitive use cases as well.
But here, we have 3 data
sources. Uh, so we have the EDGR
filings
that are the actual agreements that were filed
with SEC themselves. So,
uh, apparently got an attorney filled the form out,
you know, uh, pushed it out, uh, for
review to SEC.
Then there are the SEC formal language
regulations that tell us how
to, uh, the legal language that should
be in those agreements. And finally, there are judicial
interpretations, uh,
from federal judges and courts of those filed
agreements. So the model
can, uh,
use these interconnected data, uh, sets
to enable, uh, cross-document analysis
and validate, uh, the agreements against,
you know, the text, um, that's required,
the text that provided,
and how the text was interpreted.
So,
we will glance over some of these functions.
Uh, we will also publish
these in a GitHub repo soon, uh, so you'll
have access to everything that we covered here and
more, but these are just basically
crawling some data from, uh, open
source, uh, websites,
um. These can be easily
modified to, you know, download the kind of
forms that you want to download, for example,
Then comes the actual synthetic
data generator, and
um
once we do have the raw data sitting with
us, Uh, we can start
generating data in a format that is
ready to be consumed by NOAA,
uh, the NAA models that we'll use. The
format, the, uh, will depend on the model
that you use,
uh, and, uh, you can.
We recommend using Nova, but you can try this
with any other models available on, uh,
Bedrock or SageMaker.
Um,
important to note is, uh, prompt engineering
that should be provided while generating the data,
so the model knows what format to
generate that in.
Uh, quick animation shows you
how that is happening. I will give it
about 0.5 minute
for it to play.
So, you see here on the left that we have a
data generation kit, and
essentially what you see here, that's happening is chunking
the data.
Maybe we can actually go to uh still.
It's chunking the data into a
predefined set of character limits.
Uh, that is done because
if, generally,
you know, data is in silos exists in like gigabytes
or terabytes, and this will blow up the
context size
of your model, and it will
not be,
basically, it will not be able to admit,
generate any data.
So we chunk it, and the chunk size
depends on the context window of the model that you choose
again, M is the parameter.
Another parameter is N.
What N does is it defines the number
of overlapping characters between
those chunks
so that the model knows,
um, if there is semantic continuity,
if, you know, sentences cut midway,
the model is instructed in its prompt,
um, to say that you will receive
chunks of data, uh, this is the
context,
uh, try to maintain semantic,
uh, similarity.
Each chunk is actually then,
uh, fed into the prompt, and,
um,
that makes a single invocation into
a teacher model.
Uh, for our use case, we use Nova Premium.
So if you have 100 chunks, you'll have 100 invocations
that finally generate synthetic data.
Uh, we have it in a format that's consumable
by our student model, which is NoA Light,
and we fine-tune it, uh, which we'll
see in, in further notebooks to be consumed by
end users.
Quick glance over how the format looks
for Nova, uh, all Nova
family or SFT particularly.
You have a system prompt where you define, uh,
what you would want
the model to do or the agent
application to do. Here, uh, for
example, we would say something like, you're
a helpful legal assistant.
Please help me ensure that my
agreements are to point.
We can look at an example.
Of how that
is after generation.
It is a bit different for RFT, but,
um, concepts are the same. You have a system prompt,
you have a user prompt that actually feeds
in the query,
and you have an answer that is generated,
uh, by the model.
These are all, uh, JSON objects,
so we explicitly
instruct the model to generate it
in that format, but as you all know,
our foundation models are non-deterministic
in Some form.
So we do, uh, provide a validation
loop, uh, to ensure that these can
be consumed by our underlying model.
Ultimately, our goal is
for this model to select the right
tools, given an input query.
So we measure what good looks like by measuring
some metrics about the tools that it
selected. So
given a query, did it select the right tool?
If it needed multiple tools, did it select it
in the right sequence.
The tools are essentially Python functions,
so they take parameters.
Did it provide the tool the right parameters
that it needs to perform the query?
So these are some metrics that we are tracking. These
are customizable. Uh, you can provide your own metrics
as well, and we'll look at that in code
in a second.
But for now, let's look at the
prompt that we provide to the synthetic
data generator.
You'll see some annotations here. You'll see
double hashes, guidelines, and caps.
Each, uh, foundation model has
prompting, uh, best practices.
So for NA, this is what it looks like, and
we've incorporated it here. We tell
the model what it needs to do in the prompt, uh,
through these annotations.
Uh, we tell it what tools it has
access to and what it, uh, needs, uh,
what, what each tool needs
as a parameter.
We also tell the model to classify each
query into 8 predetermined, uh,
predetermined categories. So
those then finally map to
what tools it will use.
There's a quick,
there's a table that I can go
over.
That shows how that works. Basically, if it's
a regulation definition, this is the tool that
should be used.
If it's a regulatory compliance analysis,
two tools should be used in this sequence.
And finally, we tell them all that we want,
um, strictly JSON schema that adheres
to this structure.
We also provide some example definitions,
um,
essentially doing a few short prompting in
this, um, of how the
data should look like.
And finally, at the end, we insert the chunk
that was generated by the synthetic data
toolkit. The
toolkit that we used in
This session is uh uh an open
source toolkit by uh Meta.
It's called uh Synthetic Data Toolit.
Uh, what,
again, you can use any open-source framework,
um,
for this, uh, but essentially what
we've done in this code is
provided the capability to use Bedrock and
SageMaker models with the toolkit to
generate this data.
From there, um, we turn
the kit on, we try to, uh,
do a system check.
Uh, we use
the NOA model hosted in Bedrock.
Um, we provide an input prompt that just
says, hi,
and we can see the model is ready,
uh, to take invocation requests.
After which, uh,
we just basically file parse the data.
And then start generating prompts.
Once that is done, maybe we can
get a quick sneak peek of how that
looks like.
We combine it into a JSON
L, uh, JSON lines file because
that's how NA expects us
to provide it for SFT fine-tuning.
We also split it between 3 sets,
so. For
example, uh,
Nova generated this query
and what an appropriate answer should look
like. So we further feed it to the, uh, student
model and it learns how to
do this on actual user queries.
Uh, we'll pause here before going to the SFT
notebook, uh, to see how we do the actual
fine tuning and take
any questions.
What. Sorry,
uh, the GitHub is public or not? Is that
your question?
It's not yet public, but it would be
public by today. Um, so
yeah, we can, we can, it would be
available in NoA Samples GitHub.
Um, yeah.
Any other questions?
You need Mike.
Can you apply a similar process to Novasonic
or is that
down the line?
Uh, you mean customizing Noah Sonic?
Uh, no, that's not available as of today.
Um, yeah.
Maybe in the future,
if there's a use case, we can talk about where you're thinking
of custom, OK.
OK. If there are no further questions, maybe we
can move to the SFT.
Perfect. So, as Anupam, uh,
told you about SFT, the magic
with Laura and SFT is that when
you use an adapter trainer, which is
a parameter efficient fine-tuning technique,
it essentially takes 1 to 2%
of the model weights and tries to,
uh, fine tune those instead of the whole
model, which
reduces your infrastructure, training time, costs,
everything. We've seen that
if you give it pertinent data,
it gives you up to 90%
accuracy performance as compared to
full
supervised fine tuning.
So, basically, the raptor is
the 1 to 2% of the weights, um, that
Laura extracts, strains it,
adds it to the base model, and finally gives
you, uh, a fine-tuned, uh,
Nova Light model.
Since we've covered a bunch of that, let's
get into model fine-tuning code.
The first thing we do is set up a SageMaker
session so that we can interact, uh,
with the SageMaker clients, submit jobs from
our local notebook,
uh, provided the data set that we need to.
We select, uh, the
particular instance that we will need.
Uh, we also do distributed training here,
so we select 4 instances, uh,
so that, um,
training is faster.
We select the image URI, which is
a docker image hosted in ECR.
Uh,
these are sticky with the model that you
use. So if you use Nova 2.0, that'll
have a particular image URI.
From there,
excuse me, uh, we use recipes
and recipes, as an,
uh, let us know earlier, are just abstractions
of configurable, um,
Parameters
what that looks like is
You, let's say you want to define your, uh,
training hyperparameterss, the number of steps you would
like to run, your
learning rate scheduler, the kind of learning, um,
uh, rate adapter you would like to use,
if you would like to use Laura or not, and then,
um, you know, Laura specific fine-tuning
hyperparameterss as well.
Once that is done, we select, uh,
what we call in the Sagemaker terminology,
an estimator. We use a Pytorch
estimator because NA
essentially trains, uh, this
using the Pytorch lightning framework.
Uh, we provide it, again, whatever
variables we defined earlier,
and we give it the recipe, and, uh, finally,
we give it the image URI.
The data that we generated in the previous notebook
and start training.
So this is a completed notebook,
just to show you how it looks in the console.
From here, you can look at some metrics
about the infrastructure utilization,
look at logs.
You see one log stream each for each
instance that it trained on.
Which exited each with a status 200
code, which means training was successful.
OK, So training, uh,
takes anywhere between 20 to 40 minutes.
Uh, typical workflow, ML workflow
is after you're done with training, you want to look at, uh,
training validation curves. So we download,
um, the model Tarball,
uh, of the fine-tuned data, extract
it, which has a manifest
file and a.
Train loss file that tells us, uh, how
the model converged. As you can see from
step, we gave it 100 steps, but from
step 0 to 100, it converged
from
70 to 10, which is pretty
good performance on
the train
set only. Now
one thing to keep in mind is this
evaluation metric is actually
different from our evaluation metrics
that we want to test the model on because we actually
want to see what
tools it selected, you know, the series
that it selected it in, and if it
was Jason possible, things like that.
So the training curve is just telling you if
it matched
the same output that was in
the training data, which is.
Essentially what the
assistant responds with. So it's a text to text
match. If it, if it was a match, the
training laws converged.
OK. So from there,
we are, uh, measuring the accuracy
of
tool selection by a couple of metrics here. Some are,
um, traditional classical
accuracy metrics. So, you see precision recall,
F1 on tool,
which is if, uh, how many times,
um, was the tool selection done properly,
how many times, uh, you, you saw false positives,
and what, um, the AUROC
curve looks like and what F1 looks
like. We also have an overall
score that is weighted, uh,
based on
the parameters that were provided to the tool,
and the tools that it selected and the sequence that
it's selected in. These are customizable.
One thing that's different, um,
between the evaluation that happens
in the training loop versus what
we do is
in, in the eval loop, you have this test
split that was sent to
the base model, and then it was sent to the
fine-tune model.
The way we evaluate these metrics
is we have predefined functions
that are loaded in lambda.
So on each invocation of
the base model, as you see on the left,
The answer goes to a lambda function.
The lambda evaluates it for customizable
functions and sends those metrics
back to the base model. It does that for the fine-tuned
model as well,
and at the end, we just compare the both.
Base model eval and fine-tuned model eval
look very similar to a training job. So
you select, uh,
instance types, counts, the image URI,
which is different,
um, than the training loop.
You configure recipes again, uh, that
point in the recipe, it points
to the lambda ARN of the lambda that we
have just configured. We define the pitot
estimator just like we did.
We provided with a test split.
Start the evaluation job.
It takes about 20 minutes from there,
we want to look at.
Download the tarball again and
look at what the results.
are visually.
Maybe zoom out.
OK. So, these are metrics on
the base model itself. It wasn't fine-tuned.
We'll have similarly for the fine-tuned model.
Going significantly up and then we compare.
So you can see overall score has jumped
from 44% to 75%
on the SFT loop.
Uh, this is where we end the SFT cycle.
We take this SFT fine-tune model
and then further try to increase its accuracy
by doing RFT.
Uh
OK, so now, uh, now
that we have customized, uh,
adapter,
let's move to the RFT which is
a cool part of it.
So in, uh, RFT, as I explained,
it's basically doing a rollout,
which is going to generate a number of
responses,
and then a trainer, which will take the feedback
that is coming from the reward function, which
is a lambda, and use that
feedback from that reward function.
To update it weights,
improve itself,
and then do that cycle multiple times.
Uh, again, that the multiple times
can be defined at the step in the steps,
which is a recipe parameter,
number of rollouts that you want can be defined
in the recipe parameter.
So those things are hyperparameterss
that are configurable.
Uh, so first, just the basics, setting up
the IM role,
doing the imports, uh, retrieving
the two main things from Hersh's notebook,
which was
the checkpoint after SFT because that
would be needed to run RFT
on top of it,
and the results that he showed that are
captured in a data frame.
Uh, so, yeah, for data prep, this
is the format for RFT system,
user, and reference answer.
Uh, reference answer is basically anything.
You can pass in any random thing which
you care about, which the model should learn. It
does not need to be the ground truth only.
It can be
thinking, notes, whatever you have,
because RFT is the, the, the essence
of it is that it will just learn from whatever you're
passing with it.
It will not memorize the ground truth only,
which is what SFT does.
Um,
And then we will create the data sets
in that format and store it
in S3,
and then create our lambda function, which is the reward
function. That is the critical part in getting
a good RFT is getting a good reward
function. If your reward function is biased,
or it can be easily hacked,
then RFT will go for hacking the reward
function. And by hacking, I mean, it
will try to find loopholes in your reward function
to make it maximize the reward, and
then you will, your model will just not learn that
well. So it's essential
to see how we created the,
um, reward function.
So it's,
firstly, we,
uh, so it's lambda handler and
lambda grader. In the lambda grader,
you get, uh, input as this,
which is, so in this case, you see, we
passed the user prompt assistant
response that came from one of the predictions,
uh, and then the reference answer, which is
sort of our ground truth. So we pass like
what type of information is needed.
Uh, and what tool you should be calling, what
parameters you should be using for that tool,
uh, and any reasoning why you picked that
tool, uh, and then it
returns back, uh, aggregated reward
score. Now this is a score that
because RFT works on a numerical reward
function,
so at the end, you have to return a numerical
value which it tries to optimize on.
So aggregate reward function, uh, is
right now is the, uh, weighted average,
um, as Hersh mentioned.
Uh, on all the metrics that we care
about, like, is the right tool being called, is the right
parameters being used, is the sequence of
the tool correct? Is the adjacent schema passable?
And we kind of aggregate that through this
weighted average.
Um,
so yeah, this is, uh,
so these are the metrics, uh, default values,
0 if some error happens or something.
But uh more values if, uh,
things are right, uh, and then we capture
all the metrics here and the aggregate
score at the end as well and
we pass the result back,
um, so that's, that's pretty much what
reward function is doing,
uh.
The main thing is you should make it gradient,
uh, in your reward function. It's, it should
not be binary, like plus minus or
true false.
It should have a gradient like this is good, this
is average, this is
close to good,
so that it uses that information
to optimize close to good to closer to
the best answer.
Um, and the next, we, uh,
yeah, create the lambda, push it to,
uh, push it,
deploy the lambda on AWS
and then kick off the RFT. So this is the
crux of everything.
Uh, so here we are passing the
checkpoint, which was trained.
We are passing our recipe, uh, we're
passing the image URI which is publicly
available. We are using P548X,
uh, 4 instances are minimum that are needed
to run RFT.
We'll be using NA Light 2,
as the base model.
And then we, uh, kick off, uh,
RFT job. So,
uh, again, the Pytorch estimator call,
very similar to SFT
defining your training, train data, validation
data, starting the dot fit command,
which is basically what will kick off the training.
And you can see the logs, so you can also print the logs
in notebook or you can go to the console,
uh, but you can see the log, start seeing the,
uh, steps that it is training on
and all the, uh, different metrics
that it is capturing.
Um. And this is a screenshot
of like how uh the console
looks like, so you can see it starts training, downloaded
the downloads the image,
and then begins the training.
Uh, next, we capture
the, uh, training results,
uh, because we need to see how the metrics
looks like after RFT.
Uh, so in this, uh,
we get the results, uh, which is the,
uh, stepwise training metrics to
see how the training is doing.
And this is a screenshot of, uh,
a previous run that I did. Instead of 55
steps, I did 150 steps just to
see how much it can be, I can stretch it.
Um, and then I looked at the
train reward function, train reward metric,
which is the key metric that we should be looking
for RFT, like, how is our reward
improving? We want to see a gradual
increase in reward from like a low value
to going as high as close to one,
and that indicates that model is learning as
the cycles are going through and the reward
is improving.
Um, so in this, we see,
uh, a, a decent lift from like 0.81
or 8.2 to 0.8586,
uh, in a gradual increase. It even reaches
0.9 in some cases. And that
is closely correlated to the Eval
metrics. Um, so what we were seeing
on SFT which was
around 74, 75.
It's now reaching around 88, 89
after RFT.
So that, that gives confidence that reward
functions are increasing, um, and
we also see the, the entropy is
reducing so it's getting more deterministic,
uh, as well.
And then how we evaluate, we again,
do two evaluations, one,
on the base model RFT and then second
on post SFT post RFT,
uh, eval.
So, again, the recipe looks like this
for RFT eval. You, you can define
your inference parameters.
One cool thing is that it also supports log probabilities.
So you can actually get probabilities of
tokens that are being predicted, and you can use that
to calibrate your
answers, or if you have a classifier, you
can use that to calibrate what's your precision
recall boundary is.
And then in your RL environment, here
I'm passing that lambda function that would
be used, um,
for evaluation as well, which is the same
as the reward function.
Um,
so yeah, so I basically kick off
the Pytorch, I overwrite those parameters
because my reward function
right now is just a random string here.
So I'm overriding it with actual on of my lambda
function, and I'm passing the final checkpoint
that I got.
So this is post SFT eval, which is
similar to what has showed as well.
And then this is post RFT
eval.
So next, what we do is we again unpack
the post-eval results, uh,
and we kind of
find like, it's, it comes in a dictionary,
it's a JSON file.
So we get these custom metrics from there
that we were calculating in
reward function as well,
uh, and create a dictionary so that we
can compare, uh, in like a
matPlotlib using the data frame
that we loaded from the last call.
So this was, this is how we see it. Like
the base model was 0.44 on this
task, fine-tune, made it 74,
RFT made it around 90.
So that progression
tells us that it is improving,
uh, if the RFT is introduced at
a later cycle than SFT.
We also tried to switch this up, like doing
RFT only on the base model
instead of doing SFT first, and we didn't
see that good results on that. And that indicated
that SFT is actually helping
with RFT.
Uh, because SFT is getting
the basics right, getting the formatting right,
Jason's schema right, all that, and then
RFT is improving the quality of the
parameters that are being predicted.
This is more results on a different valid,
like different metrics. This is only on overall
score. That is what we care about, but these are
the submetrics,
uh, and where we see it failing
the most, or we can still continue
doing it,
the failure analysis on it.
Improving our RFT data to
see, uh, further improvements if we
want. But that, that gives a good, uh,
indication of how
you should be doing, like starting
with your base model eval, SFT
and then post, uh SFT RFT,
um, but the good part is like you can keep
continuing these iterative loops, so you can
keep building on top of a previous
checkpoint and saving that checkpoint,
evaluating that, and then building on
top of it.
Um.
The last notebook that I wanted to
show is the deployment.
Now that we have the
final checkpoint, so final checkpoint goes as
a S3 URI. So you don't get the
model model itself, you just get a S3
URI. If I can find
an example here, let
me show, uh.
So, um,
yeah, this is the checkpoint S3 bucket that
gets loaded, but
I can find, let's see, uh,
Yeah, like, for example, this is an example of
how a checkpoint would look like.
This is a bucket, which you will not have
access. It's a service-side bucket, but
that checkpoint is, can be accessed
through the IM policy that you will be using.
So, uh, this checkpoint is now our task
is to take this final S3 checkpoint
for after RFT and somehow
move it to Bedrock so that we can make inference
calls. And that is done
through two Bedrock functions. So,
basically, what we will do is, first, we will,
Make the, export the model
from S3 checkpoint to Bedrock.
So with that, we will use the
create custom model API which will
move the model to Bedrock.
We will monitor the status of it once
it is active, that means the model is deployed
on Bedrock.
And then we will make it, uh,
the second call, which is using
create custom model deployment.
Now, this will use on-demand inference
and basically create an inference endpoint
for you of your custom model to
hit, start hitting on Bedrock.
Um, and this is, again, uh,
because we use Loa across the thing,
like we did SFT on parameter efficient,
we did RFT also on parameter efficient.
Uh, we can use on-demand inference,
uh, because everything was on adapter only,
so it can reuse the same hardware, um,
yeah. And then we finally
see the model in Bedrock, which is now,
um, hosted and it can be
made to hit publicly,
uh, through your AWS account.
So how do we change, uh, code
when we are making the inference call? It's basically
one line of change.
So this is a converse API which all
you might be familiar with.
Here, I'm passing the model ID as
base model, which is Nova Light 2, and
I just get some random results of
like. Explanation, which is useless
to me because I was asking it to be structured
output. And then
I,
uh, did the same call, but this time
I passed the deployed model ID which
is the ARN of the on-demand
inference that I got from the previous call.
And here, I get much structured
answer with the right, with the right tools
being called, like the statute retrieval
and then compliance checker.
So that indicates to me that the model has
learned and it's improving its accuracy
from the base model.
Uh, so that's pretty much it. What we wanted
to cover end to end from data prep
to SFT to RFT and then deployment.
Um, we're open for questions
if anybody has any.
Yeah, we'd love to talk about the use cases that you
have as well since we have some time, uh, if
you wanted to discuss those, but yeah.
Awesome. Cool. If
there are no further questions, you can scan
and, uh, give, uh,
free ratings or whatever it's, what it's called
CA CA, yeah, so you can give it. So
yeah, but
thanks, thanks for attending the talk.
And we'll be hanging out here. So if you have any questions,
thank you.